yesterday the great and sainted dr fauci
second best doctor in america after dr
joe biden he came out and he said he's
now for mandates when it comes to air
travel now this is completely
anti-scientific
air travel has not been a vector of
disease this entire time they have hipaa
filters on the planes even at the
beginning of the pandemic when there
were no vaccines available
there was very little transmission on
planes in fact you were safer on a plane
than you were in pretty much any other
area because of the ventilation
the cdc says it much by the way the cdc
had an entire report where they said we
were surprised to learn that planes
really were not being used as vectors of
transmission now you have anthony fouch
basically saying we want to ban an
entire group of people in the united
states from being able to fly and travel
you're basically we want to put you on a
no-fly list like you're a terrorist if
you won't get vaccinated
why per se
now they say it's to protect the
vaccinated i'm not kidding you this is
their idiotic line kamala harris tweeted
this out yesterday kamala harris vice
president of the united states actually
tweeted out by vaccinating the
unvaccinated increasing our testing and
masking and protecting the vaccinated we
can end this pandemic protecting the
vaccinated you know what protects the
vaccinated the vaccine that's why
they're called the vaccinated
i was protected the minute my antibodies
kicked in after the vaccine
protecting the vaccinated this is an
attempt to divide americans as always
okay so here's fauci saying something
completely anti-scientific but we're
supposed to believe him because after
all he is tus hians
i would support that if you want to get
on a plane and travel with other people
that you should be vaccinating
why
well i mean i think you should be
vaccinated generally but why is that a
precondition to travel
seriously why
by the way this contradicts after
factory circuit 2019. so in 2019 he was
directly asked by a reporter from
bloomberg so our masks a great way of
preventing disease 2019 just prior to
the pandemic his answer sounds exactly
like joe rogan
and the best way for me to prevent
getting an infectious disease and having
to have you as my doctor is what um
wearing a mask no no no no no need to do
that
somebody's i can see they're getting
ready to sneeze or cough walk away you
avoid all the paranoid aspects and do
something positive
a
good diet b you don't smoke i know i
know you don't drink at least not very
much so that's pretty good get some
exercise i know that you don't get as
much exercise as you should
that's dr anthony fauci circa 2019. but
now to be a member of the elect you have
to do what dr anthony fauci says even in
direct contradiction to it is amazing by
the way we've gone this entire pandemic
and there's been no systematic
discussion of whether americans should
exercise that is kind of an amazing
thing you can be both pro-vaccine and
pro-exercise which by the way would be
the actual scientific position here that
vaccines are good and also it is better
not to be fat
okay it is better as a health matter not
to be overweight
that does not mean there aren't people
who struggle with it but there are a lot
of people who are not doing their
exercise and not eating healthy that is
just a reality in the united states
whenever people talk about the health
gaps in the united states versus
scandinavia it's because we're way
fatter than scandinavia it's not because
our medical system sucks it's because
our medical system can't fix the fact
that many of us are gigantic
and that is just a reality
but again
anthony fatty is a member of the elect
so you have to listen to him and if you
don't listen to him then you are cast
into the outer darkness and now they're
they're making it more more radical
right zeke emanuel says you'll be cast
into the outer darkness if you don't
want to mask or or vaccinate your small
children
now again i'm wondering where like there
better be some pretty exorbitant data on
the lack of risk to children from this
vaccine because the lack of risk from
covet is well
substantiated at this point in the
united states the number of children
under the age of 18 who have died in the
united states from covet is 412 over the
course of a year and a half during this
pandemic as opposed to well over 950 who
died from pneumonia in that same exact
period of time here's f here is uh zeke
emmanuel however saying we need to
actually mandate that small school
children get the vaccine
only 40 percent of those kids 12 to 15
have gotten fully vaccinated we really
need that number to go way up just to
give you a contrast uh adults between 65
and 75 who were so threatened before
85 percent of them are vaccinated we
need to really mandate i think 12 to 15
year olds to get the vaccine all across
the country that's unbelievable okay
what he's saying he just compared
vaccination rates among 12 to 15 year
olds for whom we are talking about maybe
a couple a few dozen deaths everyone
terrible but a few dozen deaths over the
course of a year and a half he's
comparing that to people and their rates
65 and older which is everyone who died
in the united states
is a disease that heavily skews toward
killing the elderly
meanwhile the administration again
contra the science is saying that
everybody should get boosters its own
cdc is like nope
the cdc and the who are both like yeah
we're not seeing it guys like we looked
at the data
and um what we are saying is that the
vaccination had 95 effectiveness against
severe disease from both delta and alpha
more than 80 effectiveness in protecting
against infection from those variants
they noted that waning antibody levels
don't necessarily correlate with a
decrease in effectiveness against severe
disease because you got t cell and b
cell immunity right
boosters may eventually be needed save
the scientists but there could be risks
if boosters were widely introduced too
soon or too frequently
because it might create adverse
reactions when you do too many shots too
fast
and yet the biden administration is
rushing forward with this sort of stuff
and apparently if you note any of this
then you will be cast into the outer
darkness and then then you're one of the
bad people
it's it's all about the it's all about
being a member of the elect versus a
member of the non-elect and that is why
our politics are so broken and they're
not getting fixed anytime soon because
the culture war issue of our time is
whether you think your neighbor is a bad
person it is not the vaccine
it is not
it is not racial issues it is not tax
issues it is none of that
it's whether you are oriented against
the institutions of the country and are
therefore part of the revolutionary
vanguard while benefiting from it or
if you're not
that is how we determine
there is a reason why i mean there's a
poll that just came out
a scott rasmussen national survey and
this is backed by other data i mean
kirsten solza sanderson did a poll last
year basically finding the same thing
and what this poll found is that 57
percent of democratic voters believe
that supporters of donald trump are a
serious threat to the nation
so they literally believe that half of
their fellow americans are a serious
threat to the nation itself
that is as opposed to say the taliban
only 44 of democrats believe that the
taliban are a threat to the country or
believe that china is a threat to the
country
or believe that defund the police
activists are a threat to the country
of democrats believed unvaccinated
americans are a threat to the country
again once you're vaccinated they're not
a threat to you
okay only 37 believe that russia is a
threat to the country
fully 57 percent believe that donald
donald trump supporters are a threat to
the country
now if you look at how
non-identifying voters
rank these issues in terms of who they
think is a threat to the country
not gop not done in this poll
the top threats according to the
independent voters are in order taliban
china defund the police activists
unvaccinated americans russia donald
trump supporters illegal immigrants and
socialists
and trump supporters and socialists are
basically on par with one another
according to sort of independent voters
okay but when you take a large
percentage of the country 40 of the
country and you say what makes you good
or what makes you bad is your agreement
with my dumb slogan on the back of my
address and anything that we say
together that is oriented against this
other group of people you don't care if
they lose their jobs they're they're the
baddies
then what you end up with is a country
that is broken beyond repair and you're
not gonna it's not a shock that you're
gonna end up with the sorting mechanism
that you've seen in terms of american
population movements
it is not a shock that you've seen
people like me and my family move from
california to florida because who wants
to live in an area where your neighbors
look at you cross-eyed because you voted
a way that didn't want you to vote or
because you live a lifestyle they don't
want you to live who wants to do that
the answer is nobody and so what you're
gonna end up with because of the culture
war stuff it is all culture war all the
way down donald trump was not elected
because of the economic program donald
trump was not elected because of his
foreign policy program no one could name
what those programs were in 2016. he was
elected
because donald trump was a giant fu to
this entire group of people who say that
anyone who disagrees with them is part
of the of the damned and are going
straight to hell
there is a paganistic religious
perspective and what you see at the met
gala every single year is the pagan
priesthood at work
and if you if you can't see that that is
why
it's amazing because i think the
independent voter the republican voter
they look at democrats and like i don't
understand why people
are are treating joe biden or treating
this administration or treating barack
obama for that matter treating these
people like they're good at what they do
like who looks at the way that these
folks handle the issues and thinks to
themselves i those people need more
control over my life you understand
for the people who vote for that it is
not
about
that group of people having more control
over their lives it's about they are
willing to take the hit so that they
will have control over your life
there's a very famous episode
in the uh extended bible not five books
of moses but in the prophets there's a
very famous episode in which two women
come to king solomon
and they are fighting over the identity
of a baby so they both had babies at the
same exact time one their baby died the
other the baby lived and the woman whose
baby lives is accusing the woman who's
baby died of stealing the babies they
come in front of king solomon and they
asked solomon to solve the riddle whose
baby is this
and solomon says
my solution is i'm going to cut the baby
in half
and the woman whose baby died says fine
and the woman whose baby is lit whose
baby lived says no i don't care whether
or not this is uh it doesn't matter to
me if if she i'd rather she have the
baby than the then that the baby died
and solomon immediately says okay you're
obviously the mother because you care
whether the baby lives or dies
understand that for the radicals in our
society the destruction is the point it
is not about what it is replaced with
and it is not about destruction of the
system it is about destruction of you it
is about destruction of people who do
not think like they do they don't care
if they have to take the hit in new york
by vaccinating
by vaccine mandates and and you gotta
take a vaccine to get on a plane because
it doesn't affect them it affects you
this is more about revenge against
people who do not think the way they do
than it is about promulgating anything
good or beneficial they don't care
whether you get vaccinated if they did
they would actually try to convince you
to get vaccinated if you're unvaccinated
they don't care about any of that what
they care about most deeply is their
continuing sense of moral superiority
and your continued feeling of moral
inferiority
and if they can elect somebody who's
going to bang on all the people they
hate most then all the rest of it
they can go to whatever fancy cocktail
parties they want and be as hypocritical
as they want they can hang out with aoc
and the celebs at whatever tony ritzy
gala they want to go to
because they are better than you
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content